foreign  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  clones on the run from the Empire huh  hello how juicy  the Empire is growing stronger we should  be doing more  you want to really be free then pull off  this Heist and you can have a future  rumors are more and more clones have  been questioning the order then they are  traitors like the Jedi  you all gave up everything because of me  we made the right choice Omega but there  are others out there who need our help  what sort of treachery is this stay back  foreign  [Music]  what do you need Rex any chance I could  use you for a mission  parents the bad batch new season  streaming January 4th only on Disney  Plus  [Music]